do you think film schools then more
about theory instead of tangelos you
know sometimes we don't know oh no oh no
no not yeah far far from that no I think
I'm the USU is very production base
you're still making stuff I mean and you
know you mean I guess if you would call
I guess what i was getting at before
would be that when i was there was still
adherent a little bit to the modes of
production of like a studio you know
what is a studio what is a larger shoot
crew wise look like what is what are the
roles you need you know and i don't know
that that you know i look back on some
of those kind of things and even i did
you know a thesis film there and you
kind of you you know get thrown into
this world where you know it's almost
required to have a certain type of of
shoot that you know it's an equipment
heavy and and all those things and so
yeah it's really great to be on those
shoots but it's a little less realistic
for when you're getting out trying to
make you know say a super you know micro
budget movie and which is more of the
reality for what people coming out of
film school you know can make and so
there was a lot of that within some
smaller classes but it stills at least
when i was there was geared towards okay
this is you know the higher level of
what we're going to push you towards and
i'm not sure that that even when it was
happening it didn't feel as relevant and
so that would be kind of the biggest
disconnected you know it's probably
change i would guess now you know what
would be the best way to have a DIY
school maybe someones later in life
deciding to take on a new hobby or
career and they're not able to take on
student loans or whatever it is is it
YouTube is it a combination of books in
YouTube you mean for Worlds I'll get the
instruction and well yeah I mean you
know certainly just being curious and
you know finding stuff on YouTube but I
think bigger than you know I don't think
the video you know nothing you're going
to find like reading or watching a video
somebody's going to do is going to
replicate going to making something and
so it's finding people that will make
stuff but that's the biggest you know
that's the biggest hurdle I think for
most people and that's why film school
is still very popular it's hard to find
those people that you can trust and and
who want to you know put the same work
that you're going to put into these
things it's yeah it's very difficult to
find you know and that's why sometimes
it's what you see people spring up
whether it's in other cities or things
and it feels like a little bit of a
movement because people have found you
know those those circles and support
each other but it's extremely hard to do
you know I don't think it happens very
often and so that's why film school will
still remain very popular you know
because it does that and but maybe you
know as more people want to to get out
there and make movies on their own and
yeah film school is prohibitively
expensive yeah it'll be easier to
connect with like-minded folk
you